to our major international story today
the mor the world is remembering the
last leader of the soviet union mikhail
gorbachev died at the age of 91. he will
be remembered for helping
try to end the cold war and introduce
reforms that ultimately led to the
breakup of his country the soviet state
liz palmer who was a cbs news
correspondent in moscow and interviewed
gorbachev looks back now at his place in
history
mikhail sargevich gorbachev set out to
reform the soviet union
and he ended up changing the world mr
gorbachev
tear down this wall
in the end the east germans tore down
the wall for themselves but gorbachev
didn't stop them and that was the
beginning of the end of the cold war
born into a farming family in the soviet
union in 1931 gorbachev went to moscow
to study law and joined the communist
party in the 1980s as the youngest ever
secretary general of the parties set out
to reform an inflexible inefficient
soviet system
he engaged with the u.s
and in 1987 signed a momentous nuclear
reduction treaty as mr general secretary
though my pronunciation may give you
difficulty
the maxim is dovahyay no provery trust
but verify
in 1990 gorbachev won the nobel peace
prize but his economic reforms weren't
working and soviet citizens were going
hungry and getting angry
in 1991 hardliners organized a coup
against him gorbachev did survive but
the soviet union didn't and he had to
watch its collapse from the sidelines
20 years ago as the moscow correspondent
i interviewed gorbachev
still the optimist thinking putin and
the u.s could be constructive parties
the age of empires is in the past both
sides won the cold war because we ended
it
and i've been thinking this morning how
very sad it is that mikhail gorbachev
died watching the hostilities between
russia and the west that he worked so
hard all his life to defuse so
devastatingly on the rise again nate
yeah we can trust and verify that his
legacy will be remembered liz thank you